welcome to con O'Brien needs a friend
Sona messian joining me how are you Sona
I am I'm joining that's very nice uh
okay you're not talking to a lawyer here
it's all okay and uh and of course Matt
gorley how are you Matt I am Matt
gorley ah yes yes I have many questions
um I did want to bring up something
right away this a little bit of business
I don't usually do that usually we just
chitchat we say stuff and we find our
way but I have an agenda today oh okay
yeah uh as uh as you guys know I have a
channel over on uh Sirius XM MH and um
what's fun is that SiriusXM said Do Well
by Us kid and we'll move you up the dial
I was at 106 yeah and I was like I'm at
106 now but I want to move on up well
guess what they've moved me up I'm now
if you have uh if you're in your car if
you have access to SiriusXM anywhere or
if you're on the SiriusXM app and you
say man I'm Jones and for some classic
Conan yeah which I often say that myself
that's how sick I am I'll be
alone I'm jonesing for myself um you can
uh you can check me out on 104 I moved
up two notches right congrats thanks I'm
it's now and we decided let's just call
it what it is it was Team Coco and I was
like let's call it Conan O'Brien radio
okay that's what it is so it's con
O'Brien radio and it's on 104 wow and um
this is a way that you can listen to me
it's it's I mean it's all the stuff from
30 years of Television but also the
podcast plays there too oh and uh yeah
and recipes there's no recipes okay I
shouldn't have said that that was that's
a lie and I'll get in trouble for that
um but a lot of fun stuff is going to be
on there but a new thing we're going to
be doing also is uh taking I'm gonna
take some live calls oh from anyone from
anybody in the world yeah this so this
is like without a
net yes without a net people can ask you
anything anything they want and here's
the best part I'm not wearing clothes as
I take the question sorry you said
that's the best part yeah that's
confusing oh I'm sorry the worst and
most inappropriate part yes is that I'm
not wearing clothes when I when I'm
asked questions and you can't tell it's
it's radio but I just want that mental
image in everyone's head and I have not
taken care of myself and so that that
should be in there too I mean really I
didn't wasn't starting off with anything
great but man oh poor Eduardo I'm a m
yeah no Eduardo was horrified Eduardo
got those um those X-Men Shades that's
right like Cyclops yeah he wore like a
whole Cyclops thing so he wouldn't have
to see my naked body I don't think you
understand how those work you
nerd he's the nerd I'm the nerd I'm
going to go home I'm filled with shame
Liza what happened I made the wrong
reference to the
X-Men apparently cyclops's helmet does
not work as
Shades it controls his laser eyes that's
right helmet that goes without saying
right yeah what is it are you an X-Men
expert too in in it's not a helmet yeah
yeah it's just it's his glasses but he
controls the lasers that oh
Magneto thank you yeah that's the helmet
yeah yeah thank you I mean don't just
look at me that way she knows David you
know me you know I'm an electric vehicle
Enthusiast you are and I'm excited very
excited I'll tell you why it's the
allnew all electric check it out not two
Row three row so many people Kia ev9
that's more people than I'm friendly
with this thing's incredible just off
the top of my head the Kia ev9 is the
first three Row Mass Market EV SUV try
saying EV SUV three times fast hey 800
volt Ultra fast DC charging 10% to 80%
in 24 minutes at compatible 350 kilowatt
Chargers wow that's impressive yeah if I
understood what that meant I too would
be impressed also check this out
SiriusXM offers a 3mon three-month trial
subscription to all equipped Kia
vehicles Sirius XM provides access to
over 165 plus channels they got
everything sports news comedy cone and
O'Brien radio I was waiting for that and
you know what's very cool I was curious
I was thinking I can talk about this car
but I haven't really seen it and Kia
said yeah you want to see one we'll send
one over for you to check out they're
going to make me wear special gloves and
I can't keep it I can just look at it
but uh I'm very excited for us to see it
very excited about that the all new all
electric three row Kia ev9 visit kia.com
ev9 to learn more Kia movement that
inspires are there whole uh like they
should do things occasionally where they
can't find Magneto and then they go in
the kitchen and he stuck to the
refrigerator and his legs are kicking
that's not how it works you don't know
how his power Works what mean he would
control the
refrigerator refrigerator doesn't
control him no I love the idea that he's
like just about to do something really
cool and then he gets too close to
refrigerator
andang and then someone comes by and
puts a to-do list on him buy milk get
more ham he's like God damn it you have
to know these things what if someone
calls your radio station and asks you
about X-Men stuff what if Ian I will
just oh well first of all yeah that's
true Ian McKellen might call I could
just say I'm sorry sir McKellen I'm
familiar with your other work but not
this stuff you phone in just for the big
check that I'm not too familiar with but
sir at the Royal Shakespeare Theater I'd
watch you any
day um anyway that's my that's my I
think I forget where we were going with
this your call-in show call-in show it's
a show and it's just going to be like
this except instead of you two Showbiz
phonies it's real people real humans we
should call it I want to call in real
people with Souls you probably have
forgotten what that looked like Sony you
sold your soul to the devil long ago to
get this sweet Conan
gig what's that say about you though
yeah you sold your soul too a long time
ago I sure did yeah to NBC oh yeah
hundreds of dollars in return
have you recorded one of these yet yeah
oh cool was it fun it was fun it was
really good okay Mr Gru you were there I
was there and you have the power to to
take the channel live and and do these
shows when you want yeah it's really fun
what is that Sirius XM foolishly it's
like they gave a kid with like serious
addd a go-kart that can go 900 M an hour
man and then uh they gave him some
cocaine that's what that that's what it
feels like oh God not that sxm would
ever do anything like that it's terrible
well anyway the first one's uh available
on demand what what's the phone number
um why you keep asking me things I don't
know the answer to because I want to see
you scramble
okay they were like oh what's the
molecular weight of strontium just
curious do you have that with you why
did you bring up Magneto and cyclops
when you don't know anything about the
two I know kind of about some of the to
reference them correctly look I don't
know a lot about the X-Men I know that
there's a wolverine yeah what kind of
bones he got he's got bones made of
something real
hard yeah and
uh and then I know and I know he can't
go through TSA at the airport without
causing a real fuss Magneto is always
getting stuck to a refrigerator which
emasculates him at the worst
time Cyclops keeps killing his
optometrist accidentally
now what seems to be
the if you wrote an X-Men movie it would
be the most boring movie no it'd be
really fun be pretty funny this is my
X-Men movie yeah but anyway this is the
kind of foolishness that you can hear on
Conan O'Brien radio 104 on your sxm dial
and uh check it out because it's a lot
of fun to
do